bueno en este caso para empezar la clase estoy haciendo correo directamente lo que es n8n con
npx n8n y voy a apretar la tecla o para que me habite otra instancia de mi local hostia
así que voy a esperar hasta un cacho y listo ya me está habilitando a mí y ya me habilitan
yo así que en base yo hoy día vamos a conocer o vamos a aplicar otro workflow y ese workflow va a
ser algo más interesante así que aplicamos otro workflow y aquí lo voy a colocar en este
caso en acá la parte de arriba voy a colocar clase número 6 y vamos a engrasar con open
y ahí y vamos a hacer nuestro primer sistema de negocio o sea o peña y
listo hacemos clic ahí y ahora voy a empezar a realizar lo siguiente bueno dentro de los
procesos de lo que es n8n si nos vamos acá anterior que le debíamos hecho algunas cosas no a ver
voy a ir a anterior clase de moca chito voy a irme a clases de envío con el electrónico esto
ya esto ya les funciona debería de funcionar les y a que también les ha enviado el vídeo
y bueno la última que lo que hicimos tal cual debería de estar ahí porque porque a partir de
esto yo voy a hacer los demás softwares y a los demás a pis así que esta parte sí o si tiene
que colar ya ahora voy a hacer en base a esto pero voy a ejecutar un nuevo ya voy a creer
o peña y voy a hacer lo siguiente antes a ver dónde está así yo arrancamos y vamos a entender
un poquito que es un webhook yo si vamos acá y aquí está aquí dice on webhook call algo clic
pero que me dice round of flow on resume http requests ya en este caso cuando les había
comentado en principios de clases o en principios de todo este curso les había hecho que si dominan
https le pues pueden enlace con cualquier cosa nueva y además existe dos tipos de http el http y el
https uno es de seguridad encryptada y otros sin seguridad encryptada cuando cuando ustedes han
ingresado a páginas webs y les dice seguro que quiere continuar entonces ahí es donde
generalmente nosotros aplicamos http no más pero en este caso cuando es una http ese y cuando tienen
ssh o sea algunos sistemas de certificaciones internas para autenticación ya no me pide ese
tipo de enlaces que si o si me que si o si me dicen no ve no si o si tienes que estás seguro está
seguro y me bota dos veces hasta tres veces incluso me de lanza armas o checks rojos para
vulnerabilidades y eso hay que evitarlo y cuando nosotros creamos un webcov interno de inercho
en e hay que evitar esos puntos porque a larga puede generar unos problemas con nuestros propios
clientes y así que hacemos que hay dentro de web y este web es como un oído va escuchando
por eso que dice lisa en fortes event o sea vamos a escuchar para cada evento que vamos a probar
ya en ese caso nosotros tenemos que analizar qué es lo que voy a hacer cómo lo voy a generar ahora
también esta parte es interesante http métodos son métodos del http pues en gret post delete
update hay montón en aquí por ejemplo estamos viendo unos cuantos el get el delete el hit el patch
el post del put ahora en este caso hay un programa que trabajamos bueno los desarrolladores más
lo trabajamos en wearable wearable o postman pero sé que nosotros la mayoría no sabe mucho de que
estoy hablando como desarrollador pero esto lo utilizamos casi siempre para hacer conexiones con
apis y para hacer consultas y realmente el sistema está enviando o recibiendo datos ya entonces nosotros
vamos a empezar primero con el get ahora cuando hablamos de que vamos a decepcionar algún tipo
de url ya en este caso voy a copiarme esto este orl que están viendo acá copiense a por si acaso
antes de empezar la clase bueno según el comunicado interno que me dijeron si o si tienen
que cumplir algunos puntos ya no se las tareas si o si pido que se olviden y se vayan acumulando
así que igual voy a hacer con ustedes mientras tanto vayan se abriendo esto y vamos a colocar
acá en este caso clase número 6 ya saben su nombre y van a colocar todo este aspecto y directamente
acabamos de conectar web hooks directamente perdón perdón perdón por así web hooks listo
ya en este caso voy a empezar a hacer lo siguiente ya voy a centrar esto y la altura uno
vamos a copiar los estitos ya voy a venir acá y voy a hacer lo siguiente esta parte hasta aquí
espero que lo tengan así que voy a copiarme esto y voy a pegar en mi bot
listo entonces esta parte lo primero que vamos a hacer nosotros es copiar la hora y vamos a copiar
la url es a huéreles de test o se va a hacer un test en primero para ver algo clic se copia
automáticamente ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente voy a escuchar el evento ya voy a ser lisa
y voy a abrirme otro navegador otro navegador que no sea mi cuenta de este pueden igual
manejar con su propia cuenta no hay problema pero mejor si es de otro para ver si realmente
funciona y está escuchando y me voy a abrir otra cuenta a ver de mi cuchito de google o de opera
lo que ustedes están manejando pero otro usuario yo estoy abriendo otro usuario yo voy a copiar
y fíjense dice aquí mensaje workflow was a start en ese aspecto dice que por hoy está inicializado
o así de inicializar ya y aquí si nos damos cuenta puedo observar cómo me da la respuesta
es mi get así funcionan los gets ya ahora qué es lo bueno de esto y a explicarles un poquito
interesante de esto no porque con esto yo puedo bañar sistemas porque al momento de que no se
se han visto cuando había una un mes creo que hace dos meses otros meses atrás estaban enviando
de la cárcel de palma sol y la cárcel de san pedra un montón de webhooks para robarles sus
inscripciones y poderles bañar los los correos internos y también las cuentas de bancunio más
que todo para robarles algún tipo de montos monetarios se ha hecho con esto porque en el
chanel lo pueden hacer quien sea y contar que tú entres a la url te van en todo y aquí yo ya tengo
digamos mis datos mis ubicaciones y donde desde qué equipo estoy más o menos entrando en 8n ya y
ahorita vamos a ser un ejemplo pero aquí tienen más que todo aquí dice params queries bodies y eso
voy a ver ahorita cómo lo vamos a trabajar por ejemplo si ahora vuelvo a actualizar acá
si lo actualizo miren ya no me dicen no me dicen que es me dicen un error 400 4 6 que no existe
porque porque obviamente mi lisa y hasta un webhook y hasta parado ya entonces si vuelvo a
clicar esto y vuelvo a actualizar esto debería de decir de nuevo a estar ya ahí está listo pero
aquí de nuevo se ha apagado nueve entonces esa partecita vamos a dar siguiente manera ahora para
que nosotros podamos entenderlo y saber qué es un query un query más que todo es un tipo de
bueno en informática se lo conoce como una pregunta una consulta más o menos y aquí le
vamos a hacer esto ya acá mismo al finalizar su código van a colocar bueno el símbolo de
interrogación y cuando se habilita la query van a colocar su nombre igual van a colocar mil
ton tantos tan si ya listo ahora sí ya entonces voy a volver a habilitar esto el local host internal
lisa y ahora va a estar escuchando ahora si nosotros vamos nos vamos a la plataforma y lo actualizo
ya está ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente
esta parte está medio que raro y te lo voy a modificar estos cierran la mejor
yo copié en ese de nuevo y van a ser lo siguiente ahora si sucede en acá de nuevo voy a hacerlo
listo voy a escucharlo por si acaso y vamos a hacer un símbolo escucho y ahora si van a
colocar eso sino de interrogación y en este caso voy a colocar nombre nombre mil ya
ya está entonces una vez que lo tengan hasta ahí si no se dan cuenta en la parte de acá dice
query nombre mil tan ese aspecto también va a ir a copiar y pegarlo
ya ahí vayan colocando su nombre de ustedes ya vayan haciendo el nombre de ustedes
ahora en la prueba es las voy dando un poquito de tiempo y en más eso voy a hacer darles una
un ejercicio que todos vamos a trabajar ya otros voy a pasar la lista por n8 en lo que
tocando anterior clase para tener lista de hoy
listo ya mientras tanto les explico algunos aspectos técnicos más dentro de no china ya
esta parte donde dice el pat el pat pueden ustedes modelarlo pueden en este caso diseñarlo en
base a lo que ustedes quieran cada pat puede representar una función interna de un hueco
que se que significa eso un ejemplo cuando ustedes van al banco o cuando se han hecho una
transacción ya se dan cuenta que les se han hecho no transición de bnb por ejemplo porque a lo
que sé y a lo que tengo en bancos no me da un hueco en bnb si me da si ustedes hacen una transacción
en bnb con no sé con ya pe con mero etcétera en la parte superior de su celular les sale un mensaje
que la transacción ha sido validada o usted ha recibido el monto de 800 bolvianos no sé con
ejemplo x entonces ese tipo de web hook está parametrizado por un determinado pat y cada pat
tiene un de una determinada tarea el mismo web puede tener varios pat con ese con ese mismo web
hook pueden lanzarnos transacciones a la vez pueden lanzarnos en este caso pagos si estoy pagando
por cuera una a una empresa le pago y me va danza web hook alertas alarmas jueguitos no sé por
ejemplo duolingo se dan cuenta duolingo es bastante interesante porque en duolingo cuando ustedes por
ejemplo a mí en mi caso ahorita me dice ya no tienes protector milton me dice entonces porque
ayer ya no jugaba olvidado así que ya tendría que jugar en ese web hook están viendo en su pantalla
de duolingo los que los tiene manejando o lingo así trabaja con pat sin términos ya y todos supuestamente
con web hook un montón de cosas y entonces hay uno que se ya si entonces web hook es más
como una notificación exacto y una notificación pero que está enlazado toda la red y es interesante
con ozo marahá ahorita ya otro caso interesante web de web hook es cuando ustedes por ejemplo a ver
si se dan cuenta hay transacciones de algunos bancos por ejemplo el banco visa y veces me tarda
30 segundos en darme una notificación eso es porque porque generalmente los web hook que
ellos tienen son estáticas y la mayoría de los bancos actuales tienen web hooks dinámicos y
los referimientos que significa que el tiempo es mucho menor incluso les podría comentar que
web hooks que pueden tardar años como quien generalmente los servidores de amazon web service
o ebbs generalmente tardan un año su web hook en automatizar y en actualizar todos sus servidores
cerrando anualmente la gestión eso es eso ya se puede incluso automatizar ya así que no
solamente es de en hecho en un web hook es de cualquier tipo de frameworks que ustedes pueden
trabajar pero en hecho en ella lo tiene internamente configurado y es lo más y es lo mejor y lo más
fácil porque lo tenemos a la mano y podemos manipularlo fácilmente sin estar codificando ya
eso ahora si trabajando aleatoriamente paralelamente voy a abrir metrón cmed y hagan ya saben que
se vamos a abrir telenguac para hacer lo siguiente de ahí también lo voy a buscarme una carpetita
ya saben cómo se trabaja esto ahí te estoy mi carpetita de instaladores acá ya voy a minimizar
un poco ya saben a esta parte voy a repetir una vez más control se bien acá van a acercarse de
listo ahora para habilitar esto ya les había comentado que ustedes tienen que estén grabado
o guardado su token del del en grac para no estar cada rato yendo la página y volviendo a copiar
ya en mi caso ya saben en este caso van a colocar en rock directamente con fic y espacio ad
llanto que autóquen yo listo y lo voy a copiar mi mi código
esto lo copia y lo veo y hasta ah y me dice si me dice eso de negado ya te deshabe
no escuchado ahorita no se ha escuchado pero también ha dicho mi abaz que tengo que tener
cuidado así que lo voy a desactivar 10 minutitos listo ya lo se desactivado y voy a probar de nuevo
y hasta ahora si ya no va a decir y les va a decir a otro site no es lo que me interesa
ya esperamos un poco y lo más olvidado aquí en el mío ahora si ya dice entonces como ya me dice
autóquen site de configuración ahora de siempre aplicar en en grac
y el puerto de esto es 5678 5678 listo y hasta entonces ahora si hasta ahí espero que lo tengan
ahora si vamos a lo siguiente esta misma url que estoy ahorita colocándolo voy a copiarme
voy a abrir un blog de notas del cachito un blog de notas
voy a abrir un nuevo blog de notas y voy a pegar esto ya ahí voy a pegar mientras tanto también
voy a pegarme lo que es mi mi túnel yo me pido copio esto y lo voy a pegar acá
ya está esto para no olvidarme luego ya entonces ya saben de esta parte lo van a eliminar hasta
acá donde dice webhook para no eliminar hasta y lo van a dejar y esta parte lo van a eliminar
pero para no equivocarnos voy a hacer aquí aquí abajo y aquí voy a hacer ese proceso todo esto lo
copio luego esta parte lo elimino y ahí lo voy a pegar listo y aquí un espacio de esto que estoy
haciendo acá los voy a pasar ustedes aquí y los voy a pasar y ustedes me van a inviar ahora
los tres primeros que me envíen o los cinco primarios van a tener puntos extreme así que
vamos a lo siguiente voy a abrir mi mi que se llama mi lista de mi cachito ya pero si
estoy pasando a la mensajería de mit
en un cachito voy a abrir
aceptar a los compañeros ya ya les he pasado
todavía van a colocar su nombre ya saben que tienen que hacer al último colocar una
sin la interrogación nombre igual y su nombre van a colocar ya y ahora sí voy a hacer clica
acá en lisent y así me va a admitir y vamos a ver desde donde me está escribiendo listo ahora
sí el primer que listo ya está su nombre en este caso es ángel y aquí tengo sus datos internos
ya ahorita con esto lo podemos vaner incluso
pero no siguiente ahora sí otro ya ha llegado otro pero no ha hecho la consulta
tiene que colocar nombre igual por suerte hay cuatro vacantes más
ya tendrá que colocar su nombre y apellido más juntito para que les pueda
admitir y a eduardo y aduardo que eso más lo envían para por favor listo ya está otro
no tiene nada tienen que modificar acá el que enviado disto otra vuelta
y en mi llegado otro no tiene nada todo bien tiene que colocar por ese caso un
asigno de interrogación nombre igual y su nombre con su apellido junto y a otro
ya está bien gati el día vamos voy a copiarlo y voy a pegarlo de un coche esto
y lo que denotas y luego les voy a notar en la lista el primarito el otro me ha oído su
apelido pero lo que nos con un apellido más por esto siguiente
ya en este caso está el duelo de veracolombra listo dos ya tengo dos necesito tres más
listo quien es el tercero no tiene nombre no puesto siguiente tampoco porque el cuarista
vacío siguiente ahora si quien es es maría susana mencha listo es el tercero queda dos más
listo ya aquí no me llegó nada todavía
ahora si tampoco me ha enviado el nombre
vamos chicos vamos vamos
y ahora si quien es es ángel charca listo último
listo el último ahora si
y todavía último último último no me ha enviado nombre
next next next
quien es el otro persona vamos vamos chicos tampoco no me ha enviado el nombre
ya último último último último
tampoco no me ha enviado el nombre por su caso los que acaban de entrar y están haciendo pruebas
tienen que aquí adjuntar así siglos de interrogación van a colocar nombre igual y se van a coca su
nombre su nombre de ustedes eso eso van a juntar último
tampoco vamos chicos
vamos vamos vamos últimos quedamos en cuatro ya f para todos ya no hay nada no
nadie está haciendo un get alguien más y hasta contar cinco uno dos
tres cuatro y cinco hay llegado pero no ha puesto nombre listo ahí quedamos entonces con los cuatro
que bien está enviando ahora si procederemos a la siguiente fase ya entonces este web es
bastante interesante ya y no solamente interesante en procesar antes antes antes antes me van a
sacar el scream de su documento de esa parte con su nombre en acá les tiene que votar por
ese caso acá tal cual no ves lo están haciendo y directamente a ganas ya no vamos ahora si
continuaremos una vez que hemos ejecutado eso ahora vamos a añadir algunos algunos aspectos más
para que me entiendan de esta parte también
el web es la inversión a la vida van a entender por qué
vamos de nuevo acá ahora vamos a utilizar el método post hacemos click en post
ya no voy a dejar ahí y vamos a de ejemplo ahora con un sistema un poquito más complejo
y lo que habíamos trabajado anteriormente así que voy a minimizar esto voy a venirme acá
y dentro de acá voy a escribir lo que es el el one for submission aquí estaba no voy a coca
un ad another trigger y aquí está el submission reform submission aquí está hacemos click ahí
voy a cerrar mi sustento y lo voy a acomodar acá ahí vengo ahí vengo ahí
voy a abrir el tarot ro ahora vamos a escribir el edith files para que capture mis datos
aquí está edit fills set ya hacemos click ahí
y eso vamos a hacer esta cosa ya esta parte lo voy a quitar ahora si
nosotros qué vamos a hacer con esto un web hook necesariamente va a capturar datos ya pero el
edith fills también lo hace solamente que el edith fills si es un filtro ya el web hook es el que
va a admitir vas a excepcionar datos o va a enviar datos una de dos ya y el for submission
también va a capturar datos a estos dos trabajan casi de la misma manera pero esto ya es un poquito
más anticuado les diría ya porque en vez del for submission yo puedo colocar una HTML
y puedo crearme mi propia interfaz y en vez de estos empresarios y conectarlo a mi web hook y listo
estaría yo admitiendo datos desde una interfaz propia ya entonces vamos a conectarlo directamente a
OpenEye no sé qué vengo acá y vamos a escribir OpenEye aquí está ahora el OpenEye que yo
necesito vamos a hacer el primer trabajo yo quiero generalmente hacer un aspecto más técnico para ello
yo voy a analizar qué proceso voy a hacer ya me echáis clasificar no lo sé entonces para eso
ahorita lo vamos a añadir y vamos a entender qué vamos a trabajar en sacado el delete no me sirve
mientras tanto el update hay montón de aspectos que pueden colocar yo puedo colocar en este caso
en meso y modo ya puedo generar un mensaje voy a crearme esto mientras tanto clic
hago clic y lo voy a cerrar ya así les va a aparecer estas cositas vayan eliminándolo todavía
no lo vamos a conectar ahorita lo vamos a conectar después del proceso ya entonces una vez que
generamos ese aspecto ya voy a poder generar un proceso un poquito más complejo entenderamos primero
quiero que un proceso captura datos queremos filtrarlo y esa filtración quiero llevarlo
modelo de ella que en este caso vaya recibiendo y vaya respondiendo en base a las preguntas que
estás realizando el usuario o el cliente que tengamos en spar eso yo quiero enviarle directamente
su correo así que aquí voy a podemos colocar un gmail y dentro del gmail voy a colocar en este
caso y send me ya porque vamos a enviarle un mensaje al usuario hacemos clic aquí lo voy a
volver a cerrar y lo voy a dejar en esto está bien conectado no hay problema una vez que tenemos
eso ya podemos ahora exceder también a bases de datos ya ahora si la mayoría no sabe que es una base
de datos una base de datos netamente alberga variables esas variables albergan ya datos que
ya están normalizados para que un determinado cliente pueda introducir así si se ahorita
mi one force mission estoy decepcionando nombre ciudad y celular en la base de datos tendría que
tener esos tres parámetros también para que los datos que esté ingresando el usuario se pueda
grabar en los también es la misma cantidad de datos que está resabcionando ahora hay dos
tipos de base de datos hay ese cuele y no se cuele las bases de datos se cuelen ya están en este caso
fragmentadas y ya tiene una estructura mientras la base de datos con no hace cuelé trabajan de manera
informato y son y son de manera desordenada pero tienen orden de acuerdo al al acuery que
nosotros le vamos a dar ya en este caso y voy a trabajar como estamos iniciando siempre es bueno
empezar a trabajar con cosas más estructuradas por lo cual voy a trabajar lentamente con base de
datos ese cueles ya entonces para esa parte quiero lo siguiente ahora vamos a hacer un poco
vuelvo a repetir este proceso nos excepcionamos datos capturamos los datos lo filtramos y lo
encryptamos y va a ir a mi modelo de ia y hasta ia va a analizar en base aquí quizás uno va a
enviar a mis bases de datos o dos bases va a tomar la base de datos como si fuera su fuente ya de
información o sea podemos trabajar de dos maneras para ello hago clic acá en el símbolo de más y
voy a ir a lo siguiente ya en este caso si se va a dar cuenta hay un montón de cositas pero en este
caso yo voy a buscar algo específico ya voy a buscar el http request tool hago clic para que
más sirves ya les había comentado para retornar procesar enviar datos o sea es y conectarme con
cualquier tipo de software hardware así que cuando es algo clic lo voy a hacer al esto y se va a
auto completar acá ya hasta ahí no estoy tiempo chicos estoy volando me dicen ya para
para detenerme un poquito
ya seguiremos entonces de nuevo voy a venir acá y hago clic acá y voy a escribir en este caso
como vamos a trabajar con base de datos maya se cuela en tool listo hacemos clic
nos cerramos esto mientras tanto y ya está ya estamos jugando con bases de datos y 8 de
tu per request hasta ahí tienen que colocar y sacar el screen para enviarme en su tarea
posterior y ya dan clic y vayan guardándolo en su documento van a colocar captura número
2 captura 3 voy a colocar acá captura 2
2 y listo ahora es la captura 3
esto ya una vez que lo tengan hasta ahí vamos a irnos a la captura 4
y a minimizo y hago lo siguiente ahora tengo que analizar qué proceso voy a hacer bueno
este caso tenemos que capturar esto acá luego esto acá luego esto manda lo ha secado ya así
debería estar conectado bueno hasta aquí es un proceso bastante interesante pero vamos a
les enseñar algunas cosas más ustedes quieren trabajar ya voy a ponerles un ejemplo
por ejemplo y ahorita manejo dos hospitales que tienen aproximadamente más de 14 mil
pacientes y doctores durante cinco años por ejemplo es no se podría desear que es un dato
bueno el cantidad de datos es bastante grande pero el proceso que tiene cada uno de sus pacientes
cada uno de sus doctores son extremadamente grandes pónganle que si tenemos 14 mil pacientes
voy a esperar sacar la calculadora y voy a ayudar a esta parte y por ejemplo tengo 14 mil en un total
de 14 mil tanto doctores como tanto pacientes como tanto enfermeros como tanto cualquier tipo de
áreas dentro de un hospital ya estos hospitales del hospital general ya en este caso cada ingreso
que tiene un paciente promedio durante un año se puede albergar más o menos unos 3000 datos
ya además de esos cada proceso y cada respuesta que les genera al sistema son casi 15 mil
respuestas y a partir de eso también se le ejecuta algún tipo de sintomatizaciones por ejemplo un
ejemplo que los voy a dar ahorita yo tengo dos pacientes que tienen cáncer yo generalmente les
aplico algún tipo de resunancia magnética para hacerles algún tipo de configuraciones y a su
destrucción de sus células madre para poder mejorar su procesada de adaptación así que yo les
aplico generalmente algún tipo de RMS para hacer éxito yo generalmente requiero más de un 1 millón
de datos para el servidor así que multipliquen por un millón fíjense cuántos datos yo genero en un año
y mi servidor estos datos no lo puede procesar en el 8 es casi imposible tenemos que si o si
nosotros trabajar con una empresa tercera y es empresa tercera se llama big data
ya o sea el parámetro que lo estoy mostrando se llama big data son datos grandes y no solamente
es esto si ustedes tienen digamos un negocio en la cual tienen un flujo extremadamente grande de
clientes o datos por por año es necesario trabajar con algún tipo de empresa tercera ya un terciario
y que les ofrezca el servidor tanto y como lo van a hacer datos y que los de un vacabin turn
así que para eso yo trabajo con dos y pueden trabajarlo con eso yo trabajé con el chaval así
esto hace eso o también con spark o apache spark le llamamos
ya estos sistemas son gigantescos para mi institución de datos y estos se conectan de manera muy fácil a mi
en ocho ya son los dos
ahí pueden adquirirlo no son tan caras pero si van a trabajar con empresas
normal y para que dice virgis ee
raisins por ejemplo vamos a entrar acá no se porque está tan lento
espero acá miren no está tan car
para una empresa que requiere más de un millón de datos no está tan car
interpresar es así es ya ahora sí
continuamos alguna pregunta de duda está ahí
ya continuamos chicos entonces haremos un negocio ya un
les veo una sugerencia ver qué porque negocio podemos hacer de hoy o de ser de
no sé tengo una no sé me voy a inventar tengo una empresa que vende
a ver componentes agrícolas y ahora hemos eso
debo aquí a mi 1 for submission ya hasta ahí los espero y esto un poquito grande
no ahora sí ya acá ya sabemos hasta porque ya vamos a avanzar en clases así que no va a haber
niña voy a colocar acá e empresa
y de fertilizantes
que puedo colocar y
y así lo vemos y esto es su nombre ya
somos una empresa dedicada
a la venta
de componentes organos
listo
ustedes
está volviendo a las inicios ya ahora sí
hay dios
ya volver a mostrar esta parte
ya ahora sí
entonces su captura número 4 van a colocar el nombre de la empresa o negocio de
su persona o sea de ustedes
ya eso vayan creándose porque esto va a ser parte ya de proyecto
no sé la mía ya saben que es una venta de voy a colocar venta de fertilizantes
y eso tengan en cuenta eso porque en los
escrumes que van a enviar tiene que estar el nombre de su empresa y de qué características tiene su
empresa ya hasta ahí van a hacer lo siguiente van a abrirse esto en mod incognito y van a entrar
en el caso de la empresa
denle esa esa temática
ya y voy a colocar lo siguiente
dame características básicas
en resumen
de este negocio
venda de fertilizantes
y santos
oria silo
sociedad anónima no sé
y esto
y eso se van a copiar y se van a pegar en el huerto ya
a ver
me escuchan los chicos me van a coger con un cheque porque ahorita me dice mi mi
mi pared de la conexión de raíz
y
acordando
listo gracias chicos no sé por qué estamos así
y ya los bolsos a partir entonces gracias por los ponos chips
y ya voy a los repartidos acá
y
creen ustedes ahorita mismo en la captura número 4 el nombre de una empresa o negocio de ustedes
y ese negocio le van a hacer una pregunta a chat que se los genere
más o menos algún contenido de ese tipo de negocio
y a por ejemplo ver aquí me dice tan ciudad puedo colocar esto
ya eso
listo
eso diganle y eso lo van a pegar acá
ya hasta ahí les voy a esperar a los chicos
necesito su actividad principal o sea toda la información necesaria no tan larga sino
es algo corta pero que resuma algo interesante ahora si es mejor
pueden colocar esto en párrafo no si quieren puede hacerlo en viñetas pero esto puede ser
colocámelo en párrafo
listo
ya porque porque las digo esto porque este va a ser nuestro prompt
ya cuando hagamos ya la conexión nuestra y pi así que esa parte
va ya naciendolo opción 1 pueden hacerlo con viñeta
normalmente una ya entienden más con viñetas que con párrafos pero siempre es bueno ser pueblos
y
listo ya hasta y están listos porque lo que viene va a ser algo extensa
ok ok ok
díganle dame características básicas en resumen de este negocio dos puntos y van a
colocar el nombre de su empresa nada más y a pero ojo de acá este caso
de acá en mi en ocho en esta varga un punto van a colocar acá miren empresas de fertilizantes
orias y los llama voy a colocarlo entre comillas y pueden para para que les entienda también su
prompt de chat y piti porque va a decir no donde se oye así los somos las empresas dedicadas a la
venta de componentes orgánicos y hasta eso es el principal que van a colocar y luego genera
muy aparte en base a este parámetro un prompt para que les dé una información sumida de su
empresa que se inventa no hay problema ya es un ascito eso estructura en lo bien y que tenga si
pueden chicos en su negocio por ejemplo de jabones que tengan cuantos jabones tienen qué tipo de jabón
y es todo el aspecto y ahora ahorita lo vamos a hacer independientemente pero ya tengan listos aparte
una vez que tengan eso les espero hasta ya para no saltarme mucho y nos quedamos atrás
y ahora sí vamos a añadir algunos elementos y esto tengo
form title form description ahora voy a colocar ad form y lament y lamans y voy a colocar en este
caso nombre completo aquí van a colocar lo que el usuario va a escribir o sea qué peticiones va a
dar a ustedes eso necesito y seguramente nosotros vamos a querer que nos dé el nombre completo
listo voy a colocar lo que este atributo sea de manera obligatoria
reggae file así que ven acá otro necesito su email si o si necesito su email
ya así que van a colocar acá tipo email y también que se ha requerido
que más necesitamos estoy vendiendo uria pues estoy vendiendo componentes orgánicos eso
también tienen que pensar ustedes mínimo chicos cinco datos pero bien específicos y concretos
porque necesariamente es lo que va a pedir el usuario ya necesito por ejemplo su nombre necesito
su email necesito su celular ya celular o whatsapp
ya es el tipo numérico ya saben tipo number también que se ha requerido
que más necesito a ya yo voy a manejar 4 por cuestiones de tiempo ya voy a manejar el mensaje
o sea que quiere colocar el usuario porque ya sabe que cuando venza mi form le dice que somos
un empresario de venta de fertilizantes en este mensaje como va a ser un texto bastante amplio
voy a colocar el tixoria ya listo añada a tributos que también se lo requería bueno valor requerido
listo hasta y cuatro datos y me gusta se hagan cinco cinco cinco y eso van a ser que captura y
me van a base la captura número cinco por si acaso ya es y acá abajo ya saben no es que no
quiere que los aparezca en 8n van a que el que forma es submit aquí directamente ad options ya que
dice apent n8 en attribución hacen clic y lo van a deshabilitar ya hasta y vaya yendo que esté
bien estructurado y esto me van a sacar a escrim ustedes ya hacen clic voy a sacar mi escrim y lo
voy a añadir como captura número cinco con cinco datos al lección captura cinco
listo
hasta y
ahora pueden ejecutar pero les va a salir el error a ver pero a ganar prueba yo voy a ejecutarlo
a no me salió pero mejor si no me salió porque si es que les da error acá van a ser lo siguiente
y voy a cerrar esto si es que les dice error esta parte chicos lo van a eliminar ahí
no lo van a la conexión lo van a eliminar pero van a mantener esto ya y lo se van a ejecutar
ojo si les da error en un principio yo voy a hacerlo así sin conexión todavía eso es igual a
ganar ustedes para luego no tener errores y algo clica cada dos veces y voy a ejecutar
pues tu restop y ves cerrar el otro que tenía
voy a ejecutar ahora sí ya listo pueden colocar ahí su nombre hagan pruebas y eso también van a
sacar como es cream
listo coloquen acá chicos sus correos verdaderos o correos que tengan sus cuentas para hacer
luego pruebas a futuro ya eso no se olvide no se inventan acá para hacer pruebas directas
pueden luego hacerlo de nuevo pero yo me voy a usar tiempo para no estar volviendo no tal
ya aquí si tienen que colocar un contexto de su mensaje que sea de adecuado a lo que es la
empresa por ejemplo no sé voy a como un usuario voy a responder buenas tardes o buenas noches
quisiera saber si tienen mi trato de potases
grado alimentación
y además
son muy a volver a compartir
ya vuelvo a repetir es que no lo escuchó una vez que generen los datos abran ejecutenlo
y coloquen aquí una pregunta que sea adecuada al negocio que ustedes están realizando
y voy a colocar en este caso
buenas noches que ya sabes si tienen un trato de potases o grado alimentación además ha sido
silístico por venta por tonelada
para la ciudad de cocheba
ya
y ya se está cortando de
ya y les repito un poquito
ya han hecho sus cinco consultas en el acá en su one form ahora haganlo correr y vayan llenando
las preguntas en base al negocio que ustedes están manejando ya y luego subanlo
en este caso y por ejemplo me tardó mucho por eso que tarda también ya
así que los voy esperando a usted el símbolo
saben qué es lo malo chicos y eso trimedia pasa muy rápido
ya
es parte de los risper andamien sas de volver
si no les da inmediatamente pueden volver a reiniciar y en este caso tardó mucho porque estoy
viendo si se desconecta no se desconecta lo voy a cerrar y voy a ejecutar
y ya está los hilo esto
y aquí puedo ver que ahí se está guardando mis datos yo hasta acá saque en su sexta
captura
y no agregar a su
ahora sí que una vez que lo tengan acá revita dice pin data ya un pin de era hagan clic ahí
y les tiene que decir que esta parte se va a guardar lo que se formó
misión va a guardarse va a tener estáticamente para hacer mis pruebas posterior y no estar
colocado cada vez datos datos datos esto solamente es para pruebas por su caso no es necesario que lo
hagan siempre ya es hacen clic en aquí en el data en este pincito y luego cierra y si se dan
cuenta acá les va a aparecer esta figurita y los va a parecer un conector cuando el conector
está bien siempre se coloca en verde ya ahora una vez que tengan eso recién lo van a dejar acá
listo ahora sí el edad fields debería de ahora decepcionar esos datos ya debería de
decepcionar sus datos hasta ahí lo tienen verdad
algo doble clic en edit fields y les va a aparecer esto los datos que justamente yo ya había enviado
y esto ya saben hacer porque hemos hecho anterior clase voy a jalarlo
y esta parte siempre es aconsejable colocarlo no en texto agrupado ni en texto y varios letras
o varias palabras manejen solamente una variable nombre ya listo estoy re reescribiendo nada más no
va no va a afectar a mí a mi form submission ya ahora voy a dejar el siguiente listo aquí igual
y mail siempre pues bueno trabajar lo que formato minúsculo ya le ojalos celular
ya y voy a lo escribir y luego voy a jalar el mensaje
y de nuevo
hasta ahí
ya pueden ejecutarlo no hay problema pueden ejecutar ejecutenlo
no sé qué más estoy manejando nada más ejecutar y debería de salirles esta salida
nuevamente la misma salida no podría con mis datos ya filtrados
copio y lo vuelvo a pegar acá en su form eso sería mi captura número 7
captura 7 edit fields
listo
ya hasta y
ya están si no están les voy esperando un poco más
ya no hay dudas preguntas nada no para pros o y
si me está acá
ya gracias gracias blanco porque veces no sé si estoy si está compartiendo sobre
ni más ya una vez que tengan hasta y ahora sí lo que más nos interesa el modelo de y
algo doble clic en la y ahora aquí se dan cuenta de mis inputs ya están enlazados
ya estén las a yo solamente faltan los excepcionales y aquí es donde es un poquito más no complejo
sino es un poquito tiene más pasos en este caso yo tengo ya conexiones de mis opiniones y
adelante los trabajos que he hecho así que yo voy a hacer con ustedes una nueva
vayan a crear un new credential y nos va a pedir una piquí
este apiquí lo tenemos que generar en base a mis procesos así que para esa parte voy a ser lo
siguiente no sé si lo tengo acá creo que lo tengo acá ya ahora va a ir y van a escribir acá
estos he comprado hace dos días espero que tengamos algo de dinero
openia.com ahí ven adentrando esa
dentro de openia.com van a entrar a iniciar sesión ya o en este caso antes de hacer eso antes de
hacer eso como somos desarrolladores voy a irme a la opción desarrolladores hago clic dentro del
modo de desarrollador se van a ir acá dice empezar a crear hago clic y voy a irme a poner de control
de la API a hacer clic ahí y ahora si se pueden logrear con su cuenta de gmail
en mi caso por ejemplo yo tengo ahorita 4 dólares con 98 centavos
y aquí les explico un poquito porque esta parte yo por hoy por el día de hoy y por el día de
mañana les voy a compartir mis créditos para que luego no se gaste todo y hagan lo cada uno de ustedes
como lo puede hacer pagan desde su tarjeta de débito habilitan primero la opción pagos por
internet lo habilitan el mínimo de acá chicos a los que no saben mucho esta parte es 5 dólares
en base a la hora de hoy creo que 50 bolivianos 50 y algo bolivianos ya mínimo acepta eso
se compra en el plan mínimo y créanme que los va a durar buen tiempo buen tiempo buen tiempo
buen tiempo a no sé que lo abusen con sus tokens pero por ejemplo yo he hecho hoy día casi 40
tokens para algunos clientes y miren solamente me ha gastado 0.02 dólares
así que esa parte tratenlo siempre de ver ya yo los yo los recomiendo que se compren no es tan
caro y les va a servir bastante tiempo y para muchas cosas además ya una vez que ustedes adquieran
ese producto al inmediatamente los va a llegar y van a crearse una IPA ya pero antes de acá en la
parte izquierda de su pantalla dice a piquís entro ahí y aquí está por ejemplo la piquí que crea
para ustedes ya pero a ver vamos a ver
un restrictor se puede eliminar o algo ya así que voy les voy a pasar esto voy a creer una
api que nueva y voy a colocar en 8 n no sé clase 21 ya es 21 de mayo hay no hay es 21 de mayo
ya leo aquí en de fallo para el van a colocar de fallo para y así les aparece otro normal ahora
van a colocar permissions y van a crear la cara secreta
esta clave se van a guardar siempre se van a guardar ya y don yo lo voy a copiar en mi
blog de notas yo solo te los voy a pasar ya pero primero creo que hagan los siguientes
hasta lo voy a cerrar no me interesa
ya esto también y vamos a irnos acá
voy a copiar esa clave y directamente voy a colocar esto todo la cambiar nada van a colocar 6
y aquí dice credentials successfully created y está conectado y los cierran y está ahora sí
les pasaré el código al mit
y hasta ya se pasa el código hagan prueba con lo que voy a hacer hoy día
ya se ha pasado eso hagan lo mismo y vayan conectándose les tienen que ser
successfully
hasta ahí les voy a esperar a chico antes de empezar a avanzar y esa parte ahora te vamos a
la captura número 8
y
ya vayan conectándose y esa parte cuando les diga successfully y esa parte de verdad
decirte que me ha parecido ahorita eso alguien que sacó exacto en captura y peguen su
word ya cuando le salga y lo pega en la walt
ya voy a pegar los porcentos ya
y ustedes va a decir y su accesor de mí ya lo ya ya se me ha pasado de los agravio
captura 9 y ya lo tienes chico cosi no va no lo tienes a esperar
y una vez que tengan eso
vamos a lo siguiente
y
vamos a seleccionar algunos puntos
una vez que hemos creado las api quisi demás voy a seleccionar un punto para entrenar
no ahora se vienen aquí a chus en chus y varios modelos de opinía y varios modelos
la que van a elegirse siempre ojo ojo ojo pueden elegir la el chat
o el modelo más avanzado si pero cuando son modelos más avanzados les cago un poco más de
montos monetarios yo les aconsejo que trabajen para n8n con gpt abajo de 4 o 4 ya por ejemplo yo
siempre utilizo la mini o la códix yo dice este caso la gpt 5 mini ya tiene buen nivel no me va
a cobrar mucho o sea quiero que mis tokens me duren en otros polos una vez que hagan eso van a añadir
los roles si se dan cuenta acá dice
chicos pueden avanzar clases unos 15 minutos más fuera del área y así mañana avanzamos 15 minutos
menos les parece porque no nos va a cancelar tiempo y quiero terminar esta parte con ustedes
se puede no hasta 21 y 15 máximo eso me confirman chicos ya exacto gracias rechael gracias a todos
porque si nos vamos a quedar a medias y no voy a poder terminar esta parte y decir sábado les voy a
dejar libre 15 o 18 entonces aquí quiero que tengan en cuenta lo siguiente si se dan cuenta
aquí podemos añadir más mensajes mensajes son la cantidad de recepciones que voy a realizar ya en
este caso voy a mantener tipo texto y aquí quiero que me entiendan si vamos a rol o a rol y en este
caso hay 3 por 3 tipos de roles el usuario el asistente y el sistema el usuario es netamente
quien la persona que está pidiendo no es el producto o sea el cliente el asistente nosotros
nosotros asistentes pero podemos simular respuestas o sea la ia puede ser nuestro asistente y
sistema en este caso es un proceso en el cual nosotros le pre entrenamos a la ía o sea ya la
entrenamos previamente ya algo clica en un sistema siempre van a elegir como primer proceso
sistema ya y aquí dice algo interesante dice coloquen su prompt y este prompt ya lo tienen
su prompt es el que habíamos hecho un word
este de acá en mi caso es una empresa de que yo lo voy a colocar en forma de parra folla
y esto y ese prompt lo van a copiar acá contra el red
si no se ve mucho a cada lado en lado inferior derecho hay una cosita ven una flechita hacen
click ahí y van a poder ver de mejor manera y van a poder estructuralo mejor y en este caso voy a
adjuntar voy adjuntar ojo lo siguiente a ver hasta y lo dejaremos en santo hasta y lo dejaremos
voy a hacerlo pero coloquen el prompt ahí ya una vez que ejecuten eso yo puedo ya ejecutar
por eso es un poquito más interesante pero hasta y ejecutaremos a ver ejecutenlo
van a ejecutar listo va a tardar porque está pensando ahí está pre entrenándose
listo miren ya la otro prompt y así respondería a un cliente laía miren dice perfecto entendí el
giro de la empresa comercialización de uria granulada que necesitas exactamente que prepare
que te ayude la puedo generar varios entregables y todo me da me dice que puedo hacer
mira me decía al alcance geográfico somos tantos tan hombres de empresa eso pueden añadir
ustedes de manera que pueden cocar no manda impresos a lo que le más más estético y más
organizado su prompt y con sus datos personales el nombre de su empresa no se lo que es que
el peru se le tiene que votar esta parte saca el scream porque no está trabajando ahorita con
con el toque en que los he dado
listo eso hacen scream y lo van a llevar acá
y hay captura número 9 listo
una vez que hagan eso van a cerrar un poquito y se se dan cuenta mi flujo ya está corriendo
acá de manera normal legible ya pero ahora me falta enviar el mensaje pero yo no puedo
enviar todavía mensaje si no tengo un usuario requíos de pre entrenándolo no estoy colocando
acá en en este caso sí se me estoy colocando no estoy colocando user ahora voy a venir acá
voy a decir añadir un mensaje hacemos clic en esa parte y voy a añadir en este caso algún
tipo de solicitud pero antes de eso antes antes de eso vamos a añadir un html pero antes antes
antes esta parte ustedes para la parte de gmail hacen doble clic si se dan cuenta ya tienen los
datos capturados porque está ahí está corriendo y está conectado en la opinión ahora acá esta
parte nosotros ya lo hemos hecho anterior clase ya tenemos las credenciales de gmail yo voy a
utilizar la cinca porque con ese está conectado lo que hemos hecho entre el clase voy a colocar el
mensaje normal operación enviar no voy a cambiar nada esta parte porque queremos enviar el correo
a nuestro cliente y aquí donde dice en este caso a qué cuenta va a ir o a qué correo electrónico
van a colocar van a estupen y misarlo van a irse a sus edifices porque se creen que hace filtros y
ahí tenemos que jalar este el email lo jalamos listo ahora en subjects subjects se van a elegir
algunos puntos más ya por ejemplo aquí voy a colocar los mensajes el tipo de mensaje así que
para esta parte ahorita lo vamos a hacer pero aquí dice fíjense html queremos enviar el
mensaje en html y se acuerdan que es que hacemos hecho eso entonces voy a cerrar un cacho esto no
voy a ejecutarlo voy a medir mi mesas model y huirme que brome a mi prompt voy a agrandar el prompt
y voy a decir lo siguiente genera una respuesta como estamos preentrenándolo genera una respuesta
en formato html y css para enviar a un correo para enviar un correo para enviar un correo
listo eso adjunta en la parte de su prompt y cerranlo
porque le vamos a enviar un prompt bastante estético ya ahora vamos a generar el buque que les
había comentado anteriormente voy a hacer ahora esta parte y me voy de nuevo a sentarme el google
y en esta parte donde dice subject hello world vamos a colocar respuesta a la solicitud
porque estamos enviándoles a nuestro cliente a la solicit
y una vez que tengan eso acá abajo donde dice mesas ahora si de donde se dan cuenta acá dice
mesas a model eddie fields este mesas mesas van a sacarlo de acá de mesas a modos a de mi opinión
y bien acá y acá abajo dice texto esto lo jalan listo una vez que lo jalen ya podemos procesar
ya hasta y les espero chips con esto estaremos terminando el proceso
pero hay que hacer pruebas ahora
ya entonces podemos volver a ejecutar ya
ya hasta y espero que lo tengan ahora voy a colocar aquí ejecutar world
ya
ya listo
maya ya listo eso estamos admitiendo desde mi eddie files aquí por ejemplo he creado dos
puntos ya uno es en este caso el tipo el sistema es mi prompt en el prompt tienen que añadirles
había comentado en el uno después de formato html y es este para un correo al cliente después
de prompt que se ha creado ya una vez que hay en hecho eso yo voy a colocar acá cerrar y me voy a
ir a la parte inferior aquí dice en este caso texto rol aquí a bien que me he hecho la pregunta
al compañero porque en este caso aquí me estoy olvidando el prompt que lo voy a decir en este caso
ya el prompt va a ser este este mensaje lo van a hacer acá ahora ya hasta y les voy esperando
para que lo tengan ahí sin problemas
entonces ahí en opinión y hacemos uno con user y otro con
sísteam exactamente el sísteam es necesariamente lo que ustedes le van a dar información de su
empresa de usted o sea cuán es empleados tienen que tipo de servicios que puede poder estar vendiendo
mientras en acá en el user es el prompt que estamos nosotros decepcionando del cliente
ya esto es lo voy a dejar este mensaje lo voy a dejar acá en el prompt del usuario ya ahora pueden
añadir más miren voy a tener acá y puedo decir lo siguiente quiero digamos el nombre que lo
adjunte ahí perdón le echo dos veces voy a jalar entonces no me voy a colocar el nombre dos
puntos quiero jalar digamos el celular y aquí voy a colocar celular y aquí voy a colocar también
no sé el mensaje digamos e-mail y el mensaje
dos puntos y aquí voy a colocar el no sé y me sé que será e-mail el mensaje esto no es el prompt
y en maile y maile listo aquí lo voy a jalar listo ya está es oñadarlo aquí les va a decir
les va a decir mire nombre buenas noches que ya sabéis está auto gestionando y ya aquí me estoy
aquí me estoy equivocando por ejemplo yo porque este sería el nombre no ahora sí nombre mil
tantos listos eso añadir no ahora si vuelven en este caso le van a volver a
volver a este mi caso prom hecho me le dio voy a cerrar lo nomás y vamos a ejecutar
así el user no porque como si todos aquí miren el mensaje a ver acá o si nos podemos añadir
lo siguiente al menos el mensaje más y al mensaje listo gracias esa parte me olvidaba
ya lo sí esos cuatro chicos no es necesario el email porque el mía eso vi que estamos enviándolo
y el pende emborrarlo para ya voy a colocar por hacer pruebas en el listo ahora sí eso lo cierran
y ejecuten ahora mientras tanto antes de ejecutar vayan abriendo su cuenta en este caso yo voy a
abrir mi gmail porque ese correo voy a enviarlo déjame un cachito voy a abrir mi cuenta de gmail
mientras tanto vayan abriendo igual a qué cuenta va a llegarles ya ahora si yo les voy a mostrar
si va a llegar a no y ahorita estoy dice que está ahí está listo ahorita vamos a ver si me
llegue ahora si ejecutan aquí workflow ya se está automoviendo porque el hecho el pin te dan cuenta
ahorita os voy a enseñar que me haga mi proceso y luego os voy a enseñar cómo os ejecutar de manera
ahí está procesando hay que esperar un poco porque ya le dado que el aumento de la HTML y el ccs
y voy a ver acá mientras tanto
ya
ahí está enviando el mensaje
a esta parte algo está mal
ya no le dominio dice que está mal ya sé que voy a hacer más de otra credencial que tengo
otra credencia que existen por esta parte conecten lo bien para evitar problemas
voy a hacerlo así independientemente voy a ejecutar
ahora si se sienta ven por eso dice que actualiza su aporte ahora si voy a irme a mi correo no sé si
me ha llegado también hago clic aquí en mi correo a mostrar perdón por no mostrarles muchas cosas
porque hay cosas ahí en mi correo ahí está como se lo haces y nos vemos agrícolas estimados
señores mil 32 gracias por la consulta y mira miro le ha hecho bonito su mensaje si los recibido
le confío que puedo gestionar tantos que más me dice el alimenticio cantidad requerida tantos
tantos retiro coa volteficaciones de salud y se distrae cotidica y me lo hace incluso una
un botoncito y aquí ustedes tienen que cambiar obviamente no tienen que dar en su prompt tienen
que colocar aquí en su nombre de ustedes su email de contacto de la empresa su teléfono
tienen que añadir ustedes pero en el prompt ya aquí dice si prefiero podemos conectar por
teléfono el número que nos dejó indíquenos la mejor hora para llamarlo bien no interesante
y eso es todo ahora van a ser lo siguiente hacemos doble clic acá
voy a quitar esto
hasta el despreche coste un cachito
justamente me está queriendo empujar mi perrito así que me dejó fuera
listo ahora sí ahora sí chicos ahora sí para una vez que dejan de colocar el pin ya podemos
hacer acá entre ejecutarlo de ejecutarlo de manera con otro correo hay a clic y ahora sí pueden
colocar acá y hasta aquí chicos vayan secando una captura igual pero aquí voy a mandar otro correo
voy a abrir otra cuenta otra cuenta que hemos quedado acá y acá no a la o de esto voy a irme
acá así en cógito
vamos a irnos acá ya que voy a abrir otra cuenta
listo voy a abrir mí
acá y listo vamos a ver esa prueba con otra con otro correo
ya ahora sí haré mucho prueba para ver pero me acuerdo el correo de este
correo
creen se siempre cuentas falsas para hacer pruebas y vengan a desarrollar varios
puntos para hacer pruebas siempre necesarios voy a volver a mi workflow y voy a volver a mi
voy a volver a la iniciaría ejecutamos el workflow de un coche todo
estoy esperando para el evento que esté abriéndose acá así que expiré ya
mientras tanto voy a hacer unos punts se lo voy a cerrar
esta parte también lo voy a cerrar perdonar con los ay por el robo se rompí
y se me dé así que va a tener peores esto
ya va a tener que reiniciar ya pero ya saben cómo se aplica cómo ha trabajado
vamos a trabajar acá ahora lo siguiente voy a volver a actualizarlo
porque lo eso es lo por error
ya ahora se voy a ejecutar una vez más
no se me llamó digamos Juan de las casas
ya voy a colocar el email que me había creado su alarmo y inventar
ya voy a decirle un buenas noches quiero
quiero adquirir uria
para procesos de fertilización
de un de 40 hectáreas
de no sé de maíz tiene de grado al inventicio
para el día de para lo quiero
para el 30 de mayo a primera hora en la ciudad
de Santa Cruz
listo le ejecutan
si los dos horarios ahorita es porque yo les robo por error mi sistema así que si me da errores ni
ya pero ahí pueden pueden generar eso de su parte
pero han visto que funciona no veo ningún problema ustedes vayan haciendo igual testin con lo que les
ha pasado y normal ya
si chico eso es lo lamentable tiene que reiniciar así que
ni modo de felicidad super sino de mismo chico esta parte pero esto se pueden hacer porque ya saben
cómo funcionar y demás ya esta parte que estamos viendo aquí en el post en el chachete
pre-pueblo es todo demás no lo vamos a hacer todavía este clase más tratado de terminar el sábado
pero hasta ahí debería de funcionar ya debería de funcionar de sí o sí
listo entonces sí que está subiendo van pues voy a intentar una vez más porque lo estoy
iniciando en 8 n así que esta parte nos voy a copiar esta cual lo voy a cerrar
y vamos a ejecutar una oventa a ver ahora si rápido escribir
ya necesito
uria 40 tonelos
disto subo ahora si
ya procesando debería de enviarme mi otro corromo
esperamos esperamos espero que no se haya movido algo cuando lo inicio todo
esa parte ya
ya van a ser ustedes unos dos pruebas y como los digo si los chicos vayan adquiriéndose aunque
cinco dólares los va a servir mucho la parte de su api que de opinión y no solamente de opinión
y pues en dengrock o de dipstick y me enviado me voy acá no sé si este correo pero solo
en box ahí está
no voy a agrandar y ahí está mi estimado mil tanto tanto tanto tanto tanto los creado y que dice ver
para poder preparar una contestación formal y con la disponibilidad dirección de entrega se
ha visto desde un dato bien x no ahí está uria 46 por ciento tiene otra sesión listo
y eso es todo chicos espero que les funcione hasta ahí esta captura me tienen que enviar
como su captura número 9 creo que es muy cuero y teneré que sus tres se me captura sus
destructuras no me acuerdo 9 10 capturas para su tarea de esto
10 no importa si lo hacen menos o más las pistas que me presenten que funcionan todos estos puntos
esos chicos bueno voy a detener la grabación y no se van a salir voy a sacar